is there a prison or is it just forced
labor camps and deaths so there are
three types of prison camps in North
Korea so they are like concentrating
camps that is Lifetime
sometimes that is more like the murderer
thieves or like criminals they send
re-education Camp those are more like
one between three years short amount of
sentences and then of course there's a
public execution and the North Korea
needs this constitutional Capital
inmates because they need to do a lot of
the chemical tests you know there's Gap
Chambers there's a lot of Bio it's in a
weapon they have to clean the nuclear
degrees they get deformative and they
die from a cancer so they keep creating
these little prisoners who do all this
job that they don't want the normal
population to be exposed to